ýstanbul the city on the Bosporus offers
a host of attractions everything from
its old palaces and mosques to its
whirling dervishes in thrall visitors to
this thriving metropolis these dancers
are Muslims who strive to get closer to
God through their movements cutting goop
from France came to Istanbul to find out
more about the whirling dervishes their
adherents of Sufism often called the
mystical dimension of Islam their
religion is more about searching for
meaning and spiritual development than
dogma and interdictions it's about
forgetting yourself leaving your ego
behind while you're whirling and
thinking about God that's the path that
the Quran shows us if you read it
properly at least that's the way our
founder Mevlana showed us the souvenir
stores in town have also picked up on
the dervish trend the dancing dervishes
sell like hotcakes but only a few people
know what they stand for young architect
Kareem Guk was surprised to find such a
mystical movement belong to Islam for me
religion is this philosophy of life so
that means being respectful having
trying to find the balance in your life
I've always been interested in dervishes
I mean for me it was kind of mystic I
was curious about it how can they turn
so long also during the summer but you
won't find any dervishes in the mosques
of Istanbul they practice their faith in
private before they lived an aesthetic
life in monasteries the Turkish state
prohibited all Sufi orders in 1925 but
later allowed their dances to be
performed in public
today their adherents are appalled to
see how the Quran is being misused for
political purposes they prefer to devote
themselves to their meditative music
what humanity needs the most right now
is love but unfortunately everyone is
only looking to maximize profit our
founder Mevlana's philosophy was my
mother is love my father is love my
prophet is love my god is love and I am
a child of love been asking to join you
at this museum and Galata house in a
former dervish monastery karen gould
visits an exhibition on the history of
the whirling dervishes the religious
order has been banned by the Turkish
state numerous times and to this day
it's targeted by radical Islamists
partly because women aren't forbidden
from dancing it's not originally that is
putting pressure on people you practice
it if you want to practice there was no
war for Sufism for example to extend it
to try to expand it and that's very
interesting
I think ahead of a traditional ceremony
known as Simha
a dervish explains how the dance works
the palm of the right hand faces upwards
to receive God's blessing the left palm
faces down to share the blessings with
this world
the dancers turn in time to the rhythm
of the music and in doing so hope to get
closer to God
these people are seem to be very
fascinated about what they are doing so
it's going like something of different
than religions the ceremony begins the
dervishes start whirling faster and
faster and seem to enter a state of
rapture spectators soon fall under their
spell Canon goog included for her these
dancers have put a whole new spin on
Islam
you